[Music]
welcome to the toilet of the
International Space Station the first
thing you want to do is grab this piece
of equipment and turn this rotor switch
turns on thing which creates a suction
effect in this hose so that you can use
this yellow element for your another one
the urine actually gets the record
transferred to another piece of
equipment which is the first step into
turning urine into potable water the
same suction effects allows you to do
your number two in weightlessness there
is a bag in here in there we close the
bag and we push it down into the solid
waste container
welcome to my hygiene corner here on the
ISS put some water on my skin and I am
so
[Music]